federal funding will make it possible
for nevadans to access a better transit
service the rtc is enhancing transit
access and transit equity in underserved
areas here in southern nevada the
services changes include two new routes
and several unextended routes it will
also include the restoration of weekend
service in areas like alta and stewart
vegas and owens and more frequent
service along charleston boulevard clark
county commissioner justin jones says
the federal funding will help one of the
fastest growing areas in the valley
specifically one in which growth often
outpaces resources and infrastructure
needs that's why i'm so excited for the
surface expansion which brings a brand
new route that will run down cactus
all the way into boulder city
plus routes on durango rainbow jones and
decatur are all being extended to blue
diamond
rtc says the service changes will
provide access to over one hundred and
eighty thousand people it will also help
connect seven thousand resort corridor
employees who did not have access to
transit